See, I seem to need B complex vitamins.
What would you suggest?
What I have is pure brand, which has folate and L-M-T-H-F-R
and B-12 is method of devolubing.
Okay, so if you don't have elevated home assisting levels,
you can't be taking those as a cancer patient.
You can do whatever you want,
but I'm just telling you in my opinion,
you really shouldn't be taking those.
We have a product on our store that is B complex-M-F,
which is methyl-free.
So it's a B complex purposefully made to be methyl-free.
So I methyl means the methyl-cobolamine.
So it's methyl-cobolamine and folate L-M-T-H-F-R is
L-M-T-H-F-R is methyl tetrahedral folate.
So these are going to be donating their methyl groups.
So these are methyl-laden vitamins.
So again, go back on our website, look at
should cancer patients be taking methyl-laden vitamins?
Should cancer patients be taking methyl groups?
Search for that in the blog,
I have multiple videos on that.
Unless you have elevated home assisting levels,
you should be careful about taking methyl-laden vitamins.
Methyl-laden vitamins are going to turn off
to their suppressor genes.
So you don't want to do that.